listen what gets measured gets improved
so when it comes to growing on YouTube
you've got to be looking at your
analytics now when you're just starting
out on YouTube you don't have a lot to
measure yet so you need to take massive
action build up a couple videos I'm
saying five ten you need to get some
momentum first but once you've been
posting some videos you've got a look at
analytics and I want to share three
quick analytics in this video so that
you can get more insight about your
content and actually grow your YouTube
channel faster but hey if we're just
meeting this is the coffee with candle
show my name is Sean kennel
I am the co-author of the number one
YouTube strategy book called YouTube
secrets this is the show where I answer
your questions about YouTube social
media life in business we actually bring
you on the show in the beginning we do
some rapid fire value and then towards
the middle of the show we dive into some
content but let's skip straight away
into YouTube analytics and let's talk
about three analytics that you should
look at every time you post a video to
make the next one better here's the goal
we always want to get 1% better with
every upload and so if you're fired up
hit the like button and we will dive
into the coffee with Cannell portion in
a second charissa Ken Jodie Jodie Wendy
great to see you smash like and let's
talk about number one the first one is
you got to be looking at this latest
video performance this is absolutely
number one because YouTube is making it
easy for you to compare your most
current upload with your past 10 now
what's kind of cool is your goal is
always to beat your last upload and look
this one just hit number one so you got
the confetti going off wow what a party
you know and it's pretty incredible and
what its gonna tell you is that your
performance is either up or down red is
bad grey is decent Green is good like go
for green you want your growth like over
here on the right side of the channel we
also have channel analytics you know 41
percent up and views for 64 percent up
and watch time
we you want to see green now do you go
through different seasons you're not
necessarily always going to see growth
but of course that's the goal but um
look at your latest video performance
and tell me in the comments how did your
last video do was it out of your last
ten you can look at this in your YouTube
studio and what's cool is it compares a
couple insights that you could get here
you could think about your topics like
obviously an iMovie tutorial on our
think media channel is not gonna be as
widely interesting is maybe how to get
free music for YouTube so this topic is
super popular and so you want to be
thinking about that and YouTube will say
hey great job your audience is showing
more interest than usual in your video
so reminder YouTube analytics don't work
great if you're just starting you don't
really have anything to measure yet
YouTube analytics won't give you much
insight if you haven't posted many
videos so let me know how many videos
have you posted in your YouTube journey
when you're just starting you got to do
massive action and don't even judge your
content just get content out there and
then start worrying about improving it I
would literally recommend 35 uploads
before you really worry too much about
analytics you got a trigger the
algorithm you got to get things going
punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face and just press
record but then you want to dive in so
secondly though is look at specific
video analytics so let's look at to what
you can do is you can skip straight to
the video by clicking YouTube analytics
here and you'll get a little snapshot
from YouTube nice work your videos
really taking off seventy five percent
more views than usual in the first 12
hours and what you see here is this gray
area is how a video typically performs
and this blue line is how a video is
exceeding its typical performance so you
want to beat your last upload I mean I
know we worry about competition out
there but like don't worry about
competition the only person you're
competing with is the person in the
mirror come on self-help quotes you know
I mean like but in reality like you're
competing against your yesterday and if
you describe to get 1% better with every
single upload then you can do great but
here's the deal it
kake's hmm you know this video has been
out for 12 hours or so it takes a couple
days to get all of the data on your
videos so what you want to do is make
sure you go back and look at maybe some
of your past video so I'm gonna head
back to last week and look at one that
maybe let's look at this let's look at
this one that is very specific mmm
interesting how to zoom in on iMovie
actually lost some subscribers that's
interesting to look at well why well
some of might have been like dude why
you upload an iMovie tutorials I'm using
premiere that's the risk you take right
you can look at views here look we click
watch time and this blue line is below
average now I'll be honest if you're in
my mind thinking about my strategies we
put out videos like this because there's
a real long-term value the shelf life is
like an evergreen video people that are
searching this for weeks months and
years to come will keep coming back and
watching this video so but at least we
have all the data collected here we can
see our click-through rate and we can
see our impressions that we can see
different aspects of the video so the
final tip number one again is always
look at your latest video performance
tip number two is study the specific
performance of the video but you might
need to give it a couple days to fully
see that and then the final tip I want
to give you is studying like maybe a
video in depth and so I'm gonna go to
analytics and look at one of our top
performing videos so this is kind of
crazy all you want to talk about views
why you snooze and before I get to this
tip I want to remind you if you have not
registered for our YouTube challenge get
registered we're doing a 7-day YouTube
influencer challenge tube influencer
calm we're gonna be talking about all
these tips on growing your YouTube
channel faster just go to this website
you enter your name and email so we can
get you all the information about it and
for seven days we're going live
basically for almost three hours a day
but we're gonna give you a real
actionable session in the morning we're
gonna give one in the evening we're
gonna have time for Q&A and it's
entirely free we are going to break
down our seven step you to a system
we've never shared this publicly and
we're going to be the whole thick media
teams gonna be on there this is a no
miss event so this is that tube
influence calm link in the description
below or if you're watching somewhere
else
type in tube influence calm and you can
head over there but you know the goal is
this what we're gonna be talking about
is to get videos that get you views why
you snooze look at this little gray line
down here this is how your video
typically performs is this gray section
but look at this blue line this guy is a
rocket just off the charts video
rocketing to success and on this page
you can see different aspects of it you
can see how your views did you click
watch time you see how it did in cording
to watch time minutes you can see if a
grew your channel one video my friends
grew by 17,000 subscribers so far of new
subscribers to the channel I want to
remind you you are one video away from
changing your life your business your
brand your influence like what would it
be what what imagine having a video that
grew your channel by 17,000 subscribers
right like that could just be the
tipping point and I'm not saying that
like of course we try to do that in
every video but when you get the right
strategies and when you work this system
that we're gonna be breaking down on the
tube influence challenge that's the goal
you get that breakout video I mean what
would it be worth to you imagine to have
four thousand eight hundred and thirty
nine dollars generated by one video but
also every like seven days you're making
four hundred and eighteen dollars from
one video right that's what this video
is producing and so the let's go back to
the lifetime of it and look that you've
got all year you can see the revenue
that it was making potentially you know
this video makes low fifteen dollars a
day and high seventy dollars a day right
and then you can go to reach and this is
kind of what I want you to see
click-through rate is one of the most
important aspects of a video and when
you look at the click-through rate the
two kind of most important things I look
at are click-through rate and audience
retention okay now this is actually this
looks a little low at 24 percent
this video is 40 minutes long like
disclaimer okay and so let's look at the
reach here and we'll end on this we
would have time to go in this we're
obviously gonna go into this more during
the YouTube influence challenge so make
sure to get registered for that but 91
percent of the views or at least the
impressions which lead lead to views on
this little right side of the screen
here 91 percent come from YouTube
recommending this content that did you
hear that like 9 out of 10 of the views
basically are from YouTube going around
holding up the thumbnail to strangers
and being like yo you want to watch a
video hey do you wanna watch a video hey
yo do you want to watch a video like on
the beat at the end of a video before
video you wanna watch a video and some
of those I'll click on that and they
click through YouTube is promoting this
video for think media for free we we had
to put in the content we had to put in
the research we had to we're to you know
put out value but YouTube's a free
platform that allows you to upload
unlimited HD and 4k content from
anywhere in the world with with the
barrier to entry being completely
leveled do you know that right now Ellen
DeGeneres Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon are
all just content creators from home cuz
of the lockdown like they're using their
phones to do their night shows y'all so
any of us can access this platform and
when you trigger this algorithm this
platform will give you views that can
lead to the fact that this from the
impressions out of the impressions
what's an impression YouTube holding up
your thumbnail and being like you want
to watch this 91% of those led to three
hundred and thirty two thousand views
really crazy right and so it goes on and
on and then you can even see you know
different traffic sources so I realize I
threw a lot at you there I'm super
excited for a coffee with candle today
so of course jump on the show you need
to have good audio you need to have a
good connection and so that I can hear
you and see you and I want to answer
your questions I want to hear how is
your YouTube analytics going and
question of the day how many videos have
you posted so far and what ranked out of
your last 10 was your last video
in your YouTube studio beta if you're in
front of your computer and you can get
in there make sure to update update the
YouTube app on your phone well update
the YouTube app but also update the
YouTube studio app on your phone and if
you've never downloaded it you want to
be a serious creator get YouTube studio
and if you have the newest version you
can actually see your top recent videos
and it'll show you a stack of your top
10 with the thumbnails so let me know
what was your out of your last 10 what
was your last upload in terms of how
that video performed now the way coffee
with candle works is if you click the
link that I shared in YouTube chat or in
heathers shared in facebook comments
you're able to jump in the back end make
sure you got your audio Dowd's your
video dialed you got a good connection
and I would love to answer your
questions about business life social
media YouTube shout me out
Rodney says I've got six videos and my
last video was 2 of 6 come on rowdy
you're in that top 20% of your uploads
you're getting better with every upload
that's amazing
Shannon my last video was 3 out of 8
love that Shannon look at you guys you
guys are dropping hits you're dropping
bangers now Shannon and Rodney I need
you guys uploading more I don't even
want you to be that judgement all of
your results you got to get to like 30
uploads to even you shouldn't even
really judge yourself that much until
you've actually got some momentum you
know what I mean like there's not you
know how they do like statistics on like
society that are probably not even
accurate they need a large enough sample
size to even get data on whether or not
you know the information is accurate
what can we really learn and so make
sure to post enough content and multiple
content now crazy Kylie I see yeah but I
need to see you if you're coming on the
show I don't I don't see your video yet
so if you want to be on coffee with
Cannell hit me with the video audio and
all of the things and then get
registered for the YouTube influencer
challenge man we're gonna have Heather
Taurus on there
Melissa Caputo we're gonna have Tony
with Tony's tip of the day Tony's like a
YouTube strategist on our team right now
killing it
and
it's slowly free you know a lot of
people have been affected by this
lockdown naturally we all have but
different people of course nearly over
30 million Americans have been laid off
or applied for unemployment benefits you
know trade lines are being disrupted
communities things are being just
disrupted everywhere and so we wanted to
say look less gifts let's give back
let's teach what we normally teach
inside of our coaching programs for free
and let's also really recognize the fact
that this kind of comes out of my
journey you know it's crazy to think
that 12 10 11 years later that we just
hit a million subscribers over on think
media right and the journey to a million
has been just absolutely crazy but I
really started that think media channel
that we were just looking at those
analytics back in 2010 at the hardest
season in my life and that was back when
my wife almost died and our church was
the some senior leader stole some money
and we'd been there for like eight years
and I've been on staff part-time and so
we were just super discouraged and you
know felt it's kind of but betrayed and
disillusioned and then the big short so
we were in a recession my friends were
in a recession we were in a recession
when I started YouTube we were in a
recession when I had to go all in and I
got clear that man I got to get online I
just got a haircut grateful after the
lockdown it was it was pretty shabby
underneath here I don't have time to
style it though from a Mandy here in
Vegas
and he was and you know what he said he
goes you know what you got to have an
online offer what I've realized during
this lockdown you got to be selling
something online and they have these
dope masks that him and Omar made that's
a smile on him and so they made a
product they put him online and he's
like I want to start shipping these
things online and and because I need an
online offer I got to move online what
does that say here's the smile mask who
wants to buy one of these there's only
like four left so they're about to sell
out they're about to be marked up you
know but like Omar is going to be of
course on the challenge with us and he's
one of the content creators over on
think media and so
we just had someone Jonny I see you too
but I need to see the video and I saw
zan sharee or xandrie I saw you but but
come back on I'm I don't know where you
went and he was like man we got you
gotta have an online offer look now is
the time I learned that back in the
recession back when we were crushed
financially that I needed to get online
I needed to figure out video figure out
live-streaming figure out econ figure
out how to make money online figure out
affiliate marketing figure this stuff
out and that's what this challenge is
all about so tube influence com
hey welcome to the show how do i how do
i say your name
lam cherie zan cherie welcome to the
show hey where are you streaming from
and how have you been affected by this
lockdown and what was your last video
out of 10 how many videos you post on
youtube so i have actually posted any
videos on youtube yet okay I guess I'm
shooting from st. Louis and the lockdown
overall it hasn't truly affected me cuz
I'm considered an essential worker so
I'm constantly in and out the house so
from that aspect I'm very blessed and
fortunate but I want to crack into
YouTube and I've been procrastinating
with that I guess out of fear for like
over five years so you offered the
challenge I said I'm about to jump on it
so I did but I'm trying to research my
my niche and I so before we talk about
your niche tell me this for five years
and first of all there's a lot of people
that can relate to you I can relate to
you I did post my first video you may
have seen it it was terrible and I would
go through seasons of talking myself out
of posting saying what do I have to give
to the world making excuses etc etc why
did it take you five years take me
inside your world that it wouldn't be
good or initially I was gonna be a
lifestyle blogger or I was gonna do
makeup so the market was oversaturated
and I didn't want to get involved in the
market because so many people I saw were
killing it and I couldn't see myself in
that space so fast for its
now after doing some mindset work it
became that there's there's everyone can
eat it's not just about oh this person's
doing great
you can do great too and the world is
abundant plus you're you got to be you
times two and no one's gonna actually
even if they do the same thing they're
not gonna do the same thing just like
you and you also got to find your corner
in the market but no thanks so much for
sharing that and I'm so excited you're a
part of the challenge it's gonna be a
lot of fun and so I'm glad you're on
here to tell me about where you're
leaning for your niche the question is
what nice do I pick on YouTube what are
you thinking so far so I haven't I don't
think I found anything that was in my
quote-unquote niche I'm an older
millennial trying to figure out the next
steps of my life and I don't know if
that's the niche or a tagline but that's
why I'm kind of looking forward in my
research and I'm not finding anything
under that or something close to it good
good good
okay so this is really good we're good
we're of course gonna talk about this on
the challenge but you want to move into
something that is that is practical and
I'm gonna give you a strategy it's
called the Amazon book strategy I don't
know who named it I named it that I made
it up and so and what I did was is you
want to go to Amazon which we're gonna
go there together and you want to pick
out you want to look at books and then
what you want to do is you want to look
at books over here on the far left side
of the screen and um and think about
this like when it comes to if you're if
you're talking about life learning shoot
if you're talking about comedy if you're
talking about anything at all like you
want to answer this question on YouTube
what category does my youtube channel
fit into in terms of one of these
categories because like people buy books
and they look for think about when you
walk into a bookstore what section of
the bookstore do you look at do you go
to and if you can't really find one it
shows how maybe unclear your idea is but
let me ask you this if you were to walk
into a bookstore
right now what section excuse me would
you walk to dancing fantasy fantasy okay
well so that's super strong because of
course that's a massive maybe it's a
teen teen and young adult maybe it's
science fiction and fantasy and that
actually would be by the way we if we
took you in a whole different direction
in your niche there's channels that talk
about latest TV shows are you a TV
watcher and book watcher I read a lot of
books but I'm not a huge TV watcher so
there's actually book tubers so I didn't
expect it to go this place and that's
maybe something to consider but like if
you it's actually kind of a good example
people who start Dungeons & Dragons
YouTube channels very focused can do
very well because you're instantly in a
niche that has already proven a book
recommendation for you and everybody
watching and the community is you want
to read tribes by Seth Godin or get the
audio book because what Seth Godin
teaches is actually that we don't create
tribes we join tribes that already exist
now a few people do create tribes like
Jesus Christ like he created a pretty
big tribe there's 2 billion you know
Christians so like he was a tribe found
and there are people who literally start
things but typically if you want to
succeed on YouTube you plant a flag in a
tribe that already exists so even says
this think deadheads Grateful Dead fans
you know think so
so that isn't maybe a pivot as you're
going through the challenge to actually
think about ok what are my hobbies and
on Tuesday night we're actually gonna be
speaking specifically to how to niche
down and I'm gonna give you a framework
for that during the challenge but I want
to go back now and actually talk about
if um we were going to talk about this
figuring out next steps as a millennial
there's like books on adulting like how
to adult how to be an adult or there's
books on like
finding your career so for example and
let me take it this direction and this
is just using that one strategy we have
about six different frameworks we go
through because really getting clear
cast Thompson had she was on the think
marketing podcast and so maybe let me
just use it as an example maybe she also
has a passion like you to help others
just figure out their next stage in life
but the way she has built her audience
is by being known for one thing which is
career advice and that's like a piece of
the overall life picture so now she has
people in her audience that she could
talk to about relationships about life
about her hobbies on her Instagram she's
got like yo I'm out on the weekend
having a drink I'm able to not only
promote her videos but she's able to
actually share challenges and quotes and
Lucky Charms but how does that make
sense well with you just share Lucky
Charms you're never gonna grow but when
you've got a clear like overall that's
actually good in the context Lucky
Charms are in the context of why do i
follow Kass and connect with her well
because she helps professionals beard
they build their careers through weekly
tutorials using practical tips that take
the overwhelm out of career and business
growth BAM what a statement right
she's really got like a clear niche is
this helping what is this resonate with
you in terms of the strategy of actually
joining a proven tribe or spit or
potentially thinking about okay maybe I
go career advice or adulting advice and
then that also helps me talk about the
overall life picture what are your
thoughts there with the final follow-up
question I think with that it has helped
me to realize that I need to
Anish down even though I had this big
broad one I need to niche down and
connects in other ways and then from
there my tribe will come to me because
what I've gathered great awesome I love
it and so hey and you're gonna be in the
challenge too so I'm so fired up how'd
you
find out about the challenge and get
connected to our community unusual it
was I watch her videos one of the videos
came up I think you had just launched
think marketing yeah and from there
there was I don't know what you would
call it and it wasn't an ad because I
have YouTube red so we're gonna add but
it was like something that said join a
challenge for seven days and I clicked
on it awesome was an Sheree I'm so
Pompey we're gonna be hanging out
tomorrow morning so thanks so much for
coming on coffee with Cannell and I'm
excited to help drill down more on your
niche as well during the challenge thank
you thank you guys have a great one bye
take care my friends
you got a niche down and yeah that's
totally true
pick up tribes man Heather will link
drop a link to that or just go to Amazon
and get the audiobook you wanna you want
to lead a tribe that already exists
what's an example here's a tip if you
just try to start like making just
random content and get any people to
follow you that's kind of an uphill
battle if you start a YouTube channel
that explains and does commentary on top
Netflix series and maybe not just top
netflix but actually a niche within a
niche all of the shows that a lot of
Millennials watch so you talk about like
new girl you talked about like new girl
facts you talked about like new girl
behind the scenes and then you talk
about maybe some of the latest shows
maybe you talk about the reality shows
the Netflix what are you doing you're
jumping into being a voice and an
authority or even just a commentator you
don't need to be an authority you don't
need to be an expert you just need to be
a superfan and you're like this is where
other superfans can gather I don't know
if you've ever done this I've done this
I have gone on after I watched an
episode of altered carbon season 2 and I
looked at Sonya my wife and I said what
the heck just happened I have no idea
right I was like who are the characters
some shows are easier to follow than
others and so what do we do I'm like
before we start that next episode we
need to head over to youtube and look at
watch this
altered altered carbon season 2 episode
1 explained right they don't know you
but they know that they have no idea
what's going in going on an altered
carbon and some homies sit down this is
how you can monetize your passion my
friends we're living through the
greatest era where you could turn your
passion into profit and you could take a
hobby something you love something
you're into books something you like to
do look at these guys and you can now
monetize that through multiple different
ways we're going to talk about that on
the challenge my point to you is stand
up and share your voice in a niche that
already exists or like Cass you know
think about what people are looking for
searching for and how they can meet you
so then you can tell them about Lucky
Charms later I love it hey we got Marla
up next Marla what's happenin hey Ethan
Roman is Mexico Mexico yes how is this
lockdown and koban 19 thing been
affecting you we are on an island that's
about five miles long right off of
Cancun which is sort of a hotbed and so
we are total lockdown tourists are not
allowed on the island no one's out
allowed outside their homes
it's 100% lockdown and we are all in
tourists businesses so with no tourists
on the island we're dead in the water we
have a restaurant that's been closed for
a month we have vacation rental
businesses that have been closed
catering businesses with no customers so
reinvention let's go well first of all
my heart goes out to you so you're
saying you've got rental properties
vacation stuff a restaurant catering and
it's all been shut down yes Wow
and so first of all what's been going on
in your mind and how have you stayed
positive optimistic it sound you're
obviously an entrepreneur so for those
watching that are maybe going through
tough times how have you kept you know
focused and and that's that's a lot
that's heavy naturally I'm sure you've
had some that's discouragement for sure
but you seem bubbly optimistic positive
future thinking ambitious tell us
your secrets so this is not the first
time I've reinvented myself and that has
become my my niche that I'm working on
honing in on and my business strategy is
my new website domain purchased is
refocused income calm and it's business
strategies to refocus your income
streams and online marketing to promote
your brand because I have a master's
degree from Pepperdine in educational
leadership actually I lived in Las Vegas
worked in Las Vegas awhile but then I
was consulting then I've been here for
ten years doing other things and it's
I've always said it's just not that hard
to reinvent yourself
so my niche is really being able to
translate skills into another business
because business is business and you
know just being able to find what you
like and I really wanted to live here
ten years ago so I sold my house quit my
job and we moved to Mexico and ten years
later I'm still here um that's super
that's that's amazing and it's inspiring
to hear about how you've your mentality
and that you've been through this before
so how can I help on the coffee with
candle show well it helps to say it out
loud um and get it out of my head and
just out loud and being able to see what
makes sense and being able to focus it
so right now I've I'm a Pat Flynn
follower I think that's how I really
learned about the YouTube challenge that
starts tomorrow you've been watching the
income stream every morning every
morning so you were there the other day
right yep yes and so that has helped
tremendously just being able to refocus
what it is I do because you know how
that kind of becomes our survival nature
is just to do what we can do and and I
don't think we as people always really
know what we do how it's unique and so I
asked friends on Facebook if I could
teach a course to you on something that
you know I know how to do what would it
be and that was a lot of the response I
got you know how to leave education and
go move to Mexico
on a Caribbean island or but it can be
anything I mean that that was my my goal
and and I did it I in 2009 I started
writing an escape plan is what I called
it in my Google Doc and when I moved
here I kind of cast the net wide on all
of the skills and things that I could do
and then I just started prioritizing so
I'm hoping that I can somehow create a
niche of that well I love that and so
have you started creating content no
that I think that's probably how you
might be able to help me I don't really
know where to start I have a list I have
an extensive list of research things and
so I mean I can do that part but do I
start with my story and then build from
there do I start with the crash of 2020
and ideas for that and then build on it
spider it out from that direction we
also have another YouTube channel based
on our restaurant called hobbies rock
and kitchen and um so we I've learned a
lot about the YouTube marketing and so
I'm pretty comfortable with where I'm
going in that respect but where I'm
missing I think is where to start with
the refocused income well I love it so I
mean you got the name and I think that
what I would do and here's like by the
way people are loving the escape plan
smash like for building out your escape
plan and no matter where you're watching
this if you being in value out of this
show but I would probably name it you
know refocused income with Marla and
maybe all for your last name on so you
kind of have a personal brain and maybe
brand and the focus for the show I would
on in my opinion I would start with
doing some interviews as well as doing
some solo rounds and I would not
overthink it so I think what's
interesting is you're super sharp you
have a lot of business acumen but you
also kind of you know if you look at my
brand and you look at a lot of what we
did to lay a foundation we start an
interview show called video influencers
was not by accident we - you know five
years ago started interviewing other
people in the space even though we were
also experts and had a lot of knowledge
because that's the Internet it's
collaboration and interviews is the best
way to do collaborations and so because
you're not saying hey let's be on the
same level and I mean I have a feeling
not that I want to pitch myself but that
myself and Pat would both jump on a 20
minute interview on stream yard or
something like that which is a good way
to growth hack early on
you can also that's batch about
sustainable you could study out Jaime
tardy in what she did with the eventual
millionaire super smart and she also got
content that led to a book so that's
kind of a networking expand your reach
play and if I was doing two episodes a
week I would maybe do an interview show
on Thursday and a tips show on Tuesday
there may be learning from what I did
and and then on that tips show though I
think that I wouldn't you're
overthinking it a little much about do I
tell my story first do I share tips
first I think you just do both a lot
messy and I would do is make an episode
of maybe one tip one story okay and and
and rock that for you could probably be
212 of you who do unlimited episodes I'm
sure from your life your history so what
I mean is do I start with a crash sure
like what like the lesson I learned from
the crash and you go look back and you
tell a little bit of a story when you're
starting keep your videos short at least
those tip videos be brief be bright be
fun and be done how I mean I'm going
five to seven minutes yeah yeah quick
tip quick story quick lesson who you are
and and then just start super messy and
fast like tomorrow you're episode like
and I you know it could be you might
have limited internet connection stuff
whatever for whatever reason you're a
minecraft character right now but if I
even just take you off the screen for a
second this is stream yaar this is 720p
this is a fifty dollar webcam although I
know that during the lockdown it's now
four hundred and fifty dollars I'm sorry
but webcams will be affordable
and so like you can create content you
could throw up like banners underneath
this thing you know that I can live yeah
so you got got the vibe you can do all
this stuff we have a live show for
hobbies rockin kitchen that we're doing
every Friday night and so we're moving
in that direction so that's good to hear
that and yeah Internet is not always
great but yeah I'm on Wi-Fi right now I
have it unplugged because what I have to
have two systems back on the island
because you never know when one's gonna
go down so I believe it you've learned
the adapt so that's what I'm do I think
refocus in come with Marla I start going
and just as you know not there's there
is no perfect plan there's just you have
a good enough plan you start and then
you pivot repeatedly as you go and so
you've got energy wisdom a background
depth of knowledge you got it all people
need help so I would just start creating
content quick i last question i know you
have to go the i also own the domain
marla reinvented and i started with that
but then I decided to take my name out
of it and go with the refocused income
because I want to do some courses like
do you think Marla reinvented would be
better because it includes my name or
you can have a brand refocused income
but you can have a youtube channel that
says refocused income with a Marla or
your first and last name and it doesn't
make it like my youtube channel
technically could be called like think
media with Sean Cannell right
and yet it's just think you know and
it's just think median is just think
marketing so even if even just that's
your YouTube channel name it doesn't
mean that it can't be the course name to
or not the brand name and that's up to
you you could just call the the YouTube
channel refocused income but I just like
the both because your personal brand and
your brand building and you can those
names later you could delete your name
off and it could become coz think about
think media I wanted to build something
bigger part way on the journey that I
got that clarity and now it's Heather
tourists Nolan moult Omar l2 Cory Malay
so it's already differently
but like it was more my personal brand
at first then it started to expand out
so this is a personal opinion I don't
know if that matters
you can even pivot 15 days into it but
I'm most interested in is those two
videos a week starting this way tomorrow
tomorrow I can do it I can do it I love
it I know you can and I appreciate you
and I'm sorry to hear man your optimism
your buoyancy your gratitude I mean you
got crushed
we got crushed ya know what we're
healthy we have a savings we were
prepared for lo season this year which
protect the ten years I've lived here
every season I go I'm smarter than this
fight and I saved money for lo season
and this year was the year I haven't
prepared for lo season and well lo
season is here about six months early
yeah no doubt appreciate you and are you
gonna do the soup influencer challenge
yes yes well yeah well we'll see you
tomorrow then and we're gonna be to
having so much fun inside of there so
thanks for coming Rimes please take your
time Hey
coffee with Cannell the show where we
talk about life business how cool is
Marla man I mean are you kidding me like
just optimism look we're gonna go
through ups and downs y'all but we need
each other we need a strong community
and you got to get around people you
need to be around the right people that
think that Marla thinks right that think
different and it's not normal to be
optimistic in the midst of challenging
situations but what's the alternative to
be negative and depressed in the midst
of challenging situations right come on
you want to get around people that are
gonna keep you encouraged that are gonna
say come hell or high water we're gonna
keep going we're gonna keep climbing
we're gonna keep building we're gonna
keep hitting what if the pivot doesn't
work then we'll pivot again come on
we're like the alternative is to either
give up or to get up and keep going and
so love Marla love what she's doing so
pumped that she's gonna be a part of the
YouTube influence challenge tube
influence calm no matter when you're
watching this video you got to get there
and the website will have details about
what's happening there but you know we
got Johnny on the show now and Johnny
tell me where you're watching from
what's your
businesses and how this lockdowns been
affecting you okay thanks so much for
taking time let me on the show
I'm what from Clovis Ohio and the
channel I just it just just started is
try it is like a fake
alright I'll fake a late night show
based at Foreman's oh hi I'm a comedian
I've done comedy four or five years
around here and so kind of not be our
new live comedy and stuff forced me in
an idea that I've always had just made
me do it you know now with the lockdown
situation here is about saying it as a
restauranteur I guess pretty good I'm
still working because I'm in health care
but I'm lucky to be still be looking a
check but a lot of people just start
going back to work
this past week in Ohio
yeah so it's cool to hear I mean as as
being a comedian you made the right move
as everybody needs to make right now and
that's to move and adapt and pivot
online and so you started to show how
many uploads so far uh I just did the
six show released last night you know
Sunday nights put them out around 7:00
and then so just six episode was last
night six and a half one of them was the
interview was kind of sketchy with my
internet cutting out so I decided not
put it out on that typical Sunday and
release it during the week and then do
another one and then I've been trying to
like chop it up and like re-release the
monologue and then the skid I write
during the week as I could tell video
just to kind of have like the full
episode and then I don't know just
little skits and stuff - that's awesome
it was about six months worth of content
yeah started the fifth April my man one
a week I love the hustle all right how
can I help what's your question so I'm
trying to figure out it's dropping off I
mean you might have answered already I
did I was I'm trying to slowly upgrade
my tech and stuff I'm shooting the
monologues and the skits on my phone and
then when I do the interviews through
zoom the quality goes down via the
webcam built into my laptop so I was
trying to figure out buying a camera
buying a laptop a new laptop or just
purchasing a webcam and then you
we touched on earlier possibly doing
that but what the price is being up but
I might go to up the quality of my
interviews with just maybe a webcam
rather going all the way up or you know
eventually getting a camera because I'm
gonna probably need something better
than yeah really question and maybe if
you can for the echo a couple tips on on
gear your debt you're absolutely on the
right track you want to start you know
start before you're ready or start with
whatever you have the best camera to
have is the one you already do have I
think the biggest needle mover you can
do immediately is lighting and you know
when it comes to to lighting that
probably wouldn't take too long to ship
you might even go like studio Pro
lighting kit and there's tons there's
like a Lima Pro for if you were to get
there the cheaper kits are kind of all
the same like like just want to probably
be fine read the reviews but you know
like 90 bucks these are pretty bright
bulbs couple soft boxes now you may want
to to like think about that lighting on
your desk if you want to best some more
money have it be a little more lean and
mean these Elgato key lights we've
talked a lot about these on our channel
are they they clamp to the bask back of
your desks and again you don't have to
spend this money cuz this much cuz you
only get one there's also the key light
air it's completely overpriced right now
because of maybe being back lit but you
just look how dope that is with just
send right on your desk so the less
people are buying lighting so it's not
as backordered and before you even buy
anything like even right now you could
be in front of probably better lighting
in your house if you got lamps and you
got some things going
you just need light and you could we
have a video about the one dollar
cinematic hack you could throw up some
like crazy lights sometimes the problems
heat but if you infuse like shop lights
and put like a shower curtain in front
of it to make like a giant softbox and
like dollar store one dollar sour
curtain and you could have some at least
light that's gonna help your laptop
webcam the most think about potentially
a USB mic if you want better
off of like your laptop webcam and think
media has got tons of videos about those
things and then getting in line for a
webcam you know I think this stream camp
we're actually giving away a bunch of
gear on the tube influence obviously
chances to win we have a couple thousand
people doing the YouTube influencer
challenge but this
we're giving away a couple of these this
one's cool because it's like 60 frames
it's a new one coming out um it's coming
soon so something like this obviously
you just don't know how long you're
gonna have to wait but it's not even
backordered it's dropping soon so
potentially getting one of those from
B&H video cued up but yeah most webcams
are being pushed to August of course you
can hustle around a friend of mine
bought one of these off eBay he was
willing to pay a little extra this is a
4k logitech braille highly recommended
and we've got our video on thick media
with some webcam so of all the different
options but they're like all backordered
it's pretty terrible so any follow-up
questions about that though improve the
light of course good audio if you can
plug in any kind of USB mic and then get
in line obviously this won't last
forever but in the meantime create
content just with what you have even
maybe just pulling some lighting from
around your house and DIY stuff okay
I've tried to pull some lighting through
the clamp lights in the basement and
then and then it worked out it looked
great with it I think I didn't know
about the shower curtain I think that'll
maybe help out because it was almost
like it really showed the the poor
quality you know what I mean because I'm
so I don't know that so well it's all
new to me but it felt like so as I
thought man now that really looks like
significantly different from when I
record like a skit on my phone and then
when I interview somebody on zoom in but
the two lights on 100 yes the biggest
thing if you can mute me is you want to
take out the harshness and so that's
this video to if anyone wants to check
it out
nolan molt did it and there he talks
about you know hit a dollar store if
they're open if not the lock down put
the lights behind it and obviously kind
of you got a Jimmy rig and set it up but
it definitely will make it's it's a soft
lighting hack which when you usually use
lights from around the house you don't
have that luxury so we'll link that up
in the description or just search that
out if you're watching this video on
think media the $1 cinematic lighting
hacks and Johnny man appreciate you and
thanks so much for coming on the show
thank you very much for dying preciate
John yeah take care of it tomorrow
awesome yeah YouTube influence challenge
see you there all right hey smashed like
if you're getting value out of coffee
with can all we have time for one or two
more on the show today and gonna be
getting ready for the challenge if you
haven't registered we're gonna basically
kind of be doing this kind of thing for
14 hours over the next 10 days really it
goes Tuesday all the way through
Saturday we take sunday off we're gonna
do Monday and Tuesday the next Wednesday
we'll have like some bonus sessions it's
all going down at the YouTube influence
challenge I hope you can make it and and
so tube influence comm link in the
description below
we got Rodney on the show Rodney are you
coming to the YouTube influence
challenge man absolutely I cannot wait
been watching you guys channel for a
long time now and it's been a it's been
great just watch I've been binge
watching all of your stuff and from
think media you know to the podcast
everything so it's just been it's been
good call me I appreciate that hey what
are you watching from and what business
are you in and what's been happening
with it lately well I am watching from
Bluefield West Virginia and I'm a coach
that started a tech channel talking
about tech as a coach and and how a lot
of coaches have asked me about using
tech as a coach and just because we you
know we get all this equipment sometimes
and we're trying to figure out you know
how to use it and a lot of coaches are
more so focused on the X's and O's and
so I really created my channel so that I
could help teach coaches all around the
world you know how to you know
continuously use our our tech but it
kind of turned into more of like a
actual tech channel for myself yeah I
love it you know what's encouraging is
of course you know about think media but
you also know man when you're in a niche
that's massive
there is room like what Zann sharee was
saying earlier everybody can eat like
you keep us then you keep putting videos
out so many products come any things to
review so much affiliate marketing so
much opportunity so how can I help
what's your question so I had a couple
and one of the first is that since I'm
doing product when it comes to marketing
the biggest thing for me is like how do
I even market product like I'm been
doing really good on Twitter but I
haven't really focused on Facebook or
Instagram
the biggest thing for me is like how
would I start to be able to market my
stuff better when an Instagram like des
setups are like a big thing for a lot of
photographers and and that's like I'm
not gonna get seen a lot and then on
Twitter I've actually been doing well on
Twitter because a lot of tech people
have followed me on Twitter but I'm
really trying to reach the coaches but
also trying to reach anybody that's
trying to have a business or any type of
admin so just anything like that how
would i market that on these social
media platforms so there's a question
how to market an individual like tech
product and get discovered or is the
question more like how to market your
own products or how to market the
channel overall and get how to market
the channel when you're using tech
products I guess because it looks like
I'm trying to fall into like tech
product like photography but I'm not
really looking for that when it comes to
social media sure well again I think one
of the opportunities to have on YouTube
couple strategies for you number one is
wide topic meaning lots of people are
gonna watch it like if people just want
to watch just cuz someone wants to see a
review of a webcam maybe they want to be
a coach maybe they want to be a gamer
maybe they just want to be a youtuber
what your opportunity is is to realize
that all those has that people are going
to be watching but then communicate
clearly about who you are and why people
should stick around or not so here big
here comes the opportunity like quick in
this video I'm gonna talk about this
particular product quick introduction of
who you are focus on the value of the
product how to use it or whatever maybe
Midway or towards the end you say now
look
here's what my channel is all about
though I'm Rodney who I help is coaches
so like really the only reason you
should click Subscribe is for this
particular type of content therefore
maybe 9 out of 10 people come by and
watch a wide viewing tech product but
hopefully you attract people that want
to go deeper or you realize that Tech is
much wider than you ever thought so what
you do is you have a party you take the
party off of YouTube just for the people
that won so you might say that want to
go deeper with you in your niche niche
niche niche which is like you're gonna
be smush smaller for coaches so maybe
like he hit subscribe for you know tips
and tutorials about how to use this kind
of tech stuff and if you actually want
to learn how to like be a coach go
deeper and learn how to use tech for
coaches join my private Facebook group
that's called tech for coaches and and
you take that party so hopefully you get
a video that gets a quarter million
views a million views what's not gonna
be a million you're gonna get like gamer
kids in there you're gonna get every
different type of audience in there
which is fine but then bring that
audience somewhere else and build out
that coaching vertical does that make
sense
absolutely absolutely that was really
good and so my next one would be so for
right now I've just been posting once a
week I started out on every Monday and
then I'll switch to Friday and I had one
video to kind of did really well so how
many days do you think I should be
posting right now I'm just doing the one
a week I thought about doing it twice a
week thing but you know yeah when it
comes to how many days a week you should
upload I think one a week is the minimum
and then what I want you to do is just
competing with yourself score your
videos on a scale from one to ten and
what you think you're best also based on
your analytics and results and so on
honest on a scale from one to ten means
man you knew the product you research
well you added information it's easy to
follow you thought it was a great video
that's like it a nine for you and then
you maybe you put out some videos over
time as you're posting and you're like
yeah that was like a form and I was like
a five you gotta just know for yourself
like what what like a nine eight nine or
ten is for you and then what like a
three four or five is for you and then
the goal is before
go to two a week my recommendation is
like you don't let it drop below a seven
and every once in a while you hit a six
if you upload if you increase your
volume a lot of people watching this on
the think media and pic marketing
community you've gone to so many uploads
a week but you're dropping threes and
twos and you get lucky every once in a
while on a six-and-a-half because you've
spread yourself too thin I think on
YouTube it is quality over quantity and
only quantity when you can keep the
quality high and so again not perfect
but like your Tuesday show or your
Tuesday upload is an 8 9 or 10 and
you're able to go to a week and keep it
at like a seven eight or nine but again
if you stretch yourself too thin and
you're just trying to hit a metric hit
like math of a certain number of uploads
but you're just for no reason and the
quality is dropping then I would rather
see one great video come out a week then
two mediocre ones great very I like that
that's good yeah I just want to thank
you guys for everything you guys do I've
been watching your channel so just
wanted to pop up on here and hadn't
really done a stream before so it was
really cool to you know hang out with
you well hey I appreciate you Ronnie
I'll see you tomorrow on the YouTube
influence challenge all right man take
care hey coffee with kennel we're here I
want to thank everybody who has been a
part of the show and will be able to
take one other one here but here's the
deal we will do our best to promote
these out I know they're at different
times follow me on social best place to
follow me on Instagram stories I usually
will give you a heads up and when I'm
going live I did today
and that way you can jump in well you
would typically to keep these to about
an hour and with the challenge happening
tomorrow I definitely have some prep to
do and I want to make sure I'm super
rested so I can bring the fire but if
you haven't registered tube influencer
calm is where you can jump into the
challenge and we're gonna be doing a
free seven-day live YouTube challenge to
get you momentum gets you views get you
clarity Q&A and we're gonna be teaching
through our system Heather Taurus of
course myself in the think media team
link in the description below if you
haven't registered
for that yet but hey connect with me
over on Instagram at Sean kennel rhymes
with YouTube channel and first name Sean
s EAN and would love to connect over
there we have one final caller today
call her it's like nah I'm gonna call
her
we got miss and Nyssa in the place hey
there Sean thanks so much
missa missa tell me where are you
watching from what's your business and
what are you up to well I actually am
watching from Ewok village California up
in Northern California and I've been a
sign language interpreter my whole life
but basically really expanding one to
becoming more on the interviewing side
of the thing as well as relationships so
what I've been doing lately is actually
interviewing some of my the people from
my church and getting their testimonies
but because some people you know kind of
have their privacy I'm not really
posting those up online I'm kind of just
got my studio going the lights thank you
for all the suggestions I'm using stream
yards so thank you for referring me
that's been amazing and I'm just right
now kind of looking at continuously
interviewing but I want to do something
back to my community so I'm wanting to
really interview the people and the
local businesses as well but also
encouraging that in relationship and
marketing and right now one of my
biggest things I'm trying to figure out
is I want to be able to use my youtube
for Miss Anissa just kind of miss a nice
alive but I'm curious to know the
playlist like is that something that's
smart in regards to that I know you're
really big on niching and I keep hearing
that from you but I'm just wondering I'd
love to do private type of things and
then maybe business and then
relationship and just getting to know
people by building relationships I don't
know if that's yeah yeah so I love what
you're doing
have you considered video podcasting is
this part of your strategy I'm awed
that's the next thing I'm starting I'm
looking at being able to do the
podcasting so yes that is on my list
great so I would say for you and
everybody watching if you haven't gone
deep in our video podcasting series
we'll link that up in the description
below and check that out you know what
we're saying when we say video podcast
is exactly what we do with think
working and that is we realize that
YouTube is a search engine YouTube is a
place to get views YouTube is a place
owned by Google YouTube is a place where
right so many of us you're watching this
on YouTube but yet you can also of
course then take audio off a video and
make it into a podcast so we have in a
way we not only have our our think media
channel where this is even streaming
right now but we also have our specific
episodes this is our video podcast one
Episode a week three three private
videos coming out in the next three
weeks couple weeks ahead right and
you've got every single episode building
out this particular podcast that is both
audio and video and and for those let me
know in fact in the comments if you're a
listener subscriber on like Spotify or
Google or Apple so first and foremost I
just want to double down on that for you
to say I think you should absolutely do
a video podcast it lends itself if
you're gonna be doing interviewing so
and even if you do it on a stream yard
by the way like we could turn this into
a video podcast we got your audio you
know you may be set set up like a Google
Doc or just part of your website that
helps instruct the guests how to get the
best audio possible if possible use your
earbuds if possible be in a room with
really good Wi-Fi or a hard line if
possible have headphones like so that
you help guests have the best audio and
then you could stream yard it and turn
it into an audio episode and maybe do
some editing or whatever so I would do
that more directly to your question
though I do think that putting
everything under one bucket with your
name can work but it's hard because
listen to this and write this down never
upload a video that your subscribers
didn't subscribe for so if I love the
give back to your community maybe
testimonies from your church but local
business owners might not be into that
whereas if you do like the Northern
California local business show and
people are like learning from local
business owners learning about trends in
the community even if you become your
your show gets 38 views 75 views on
YouTube and then like
a hundred downloads because everybody in
your community listens to it though you
become the known voice in kind of the
local business of your particular city
or your area but then again they
subscribe to the YouTube channel so they
don't miss future episodes but then you
upload a testimony from church so you do
want a segment and I think that's the
quote I want you marinating on now we
upload fit like if I upload a video on
how to zoom in on iMovie well I have to
admit the fact that someone who
subscribed for best camera for YouTube
doesn't even use iMovie they're gonna
maybe be offended by that and they
unsubscribe and they do like I lose
seven scrubbers some people go I'll give
you a pass some people go what the heck
I want just best camera for YouTube so
it's not that you never break the rule
it's that you need to know the rule
never upload a video that your
subscribers
didn't subscribe for and your strategic
is possible in thinking hmmm how much
can I stretch my niche and how much is
too far and this is two totally
different groups you know how does that
make sense it does and I keep hearing a
cup out a month ago I think you said
something about you know if they don't
like you they're gonna leave and at the
same time I want to be able to edify and
encourage business people local people
as who they are you know not hiding
anything whether they business people
they should know who's in their
community so I does make sense so thank
you for that because I did write it down
yeah and and let's remember this will
add value to you and everyone let's
remember that like life and social media
has so many opportunities right now that
if you really want to have a talk show
interview show with people from your
church sharing their testimony every
Saturday morning you could go live on
Instagram bring on a guest talk to them
for 30 minutes to an hour save that live
upload it on IG TV and now IG TV has an
archive that your church can share of
these conversations that's not even on
YouTube and it's and and maybe that's
even better because people are kind of
like interacting and and let's be honest
like that show
would never be like multi-million viewed
show but it's for the community build
and yet there and you could do play
listen I GTV so you to scratch your itch
answer to call that you feel God nudging
you to do and it's in a place where it's
very social on Instagram and you can
share it on stories and even link back
to it on a post and all this kind of
cool stuff but maybe like if you will
the more business play slash the brand
that really could maybe grow into your
video podcast and you're gonna vent
invest a bunch of energy is the business
podcast right no you know and and so
everybody listen think about like your
opportunities like you don't wanna
spread yourself too thin too soon
because you only have so much energy but
how hard is it to just like do something
you love and have a testimony show where
you just talk on Instagram live download
it re-upload it on an IG TV and and like
every week you have an archive and that
whole thing is and you build up a little
library of people's stories in your
church meanwhile where you're getting we
use like but buzz sprout to distribute
our podcast and just this is an example
right cuz because there's a lot of work
that goes into the thick marketing
podcast and of course you want to have
your stats like that's why we love it is
because you got you got your stats you
got your best episodes and and you've
got it distributed on Apple podcast
Spotify iTunes cast box podcast like all
the places etc my point is it's gonna
take some energy to do a video podcast
and you could still do both you got this
hobby thing or like just passion project
and then maybe you have a more business
based project and business lends itself
more towards I think the YouTube search
and everything else is that makin sense
on the show right now thank you that
gave me a bigger idea about what that
looks like because I don't definitely
don't want to remove myself to Who I am
and the you know even giving be able to
give back I want to be able to build
things as well as be able to get back
yes
and but I love that you said that
because the connection point is YouTube
show podcast businesses business awesome
and of course your personalities in
there yes but people want to connect
with you personally they go follow you
on Instagram like a very small amount of
people follow me on
compared to the amount of people that
follow us on YouTube but not everyone's
like dude I don't even like that guy
like yes good camera advice but I don't
like I want to follow him great but like
some people resonate with you you're
viable attract your tribe this the idea
I'm getting across is segmenting
audiences on social some people want to
go to Depot some people resonate with
your message they resonate with your
style some people just like the value
you provide and they want to be at all
these different like if you will like a
temperature gauge some people kinda just
want to chill on the outskirts man they
like they order ooh BRR East from your
restaurant once a year
some people come everyday to get coffee
and they want you to know they're like
so it's just too like this spectrum of
people thinking about your brand across
social media strategically and so yes be
yourself and so you have different
platforms to express yourself
differently it's all cohesive but I
might on the podcast only like drop 30
seconds of my story or what I believe
and some of my biggest values whereas
I'll do a live stream on Instagram live
and just go raw for 25 minutes like it's
both it's not either/or it's the mix and
of course just experimenting as you go
awesome
thank you so much I appreciate your time
yes you got it thanks so much for coming
on miss and this and keep crushing it
hey I want to give a shout out that was
fun and I want to give a shout out to if
you haven't seen our think media tools
guide in regards to like what are you
guys used for podcasting what do you
guys use for video editing what do you
guys use for music what do you guys use
for streaming we're on stream yard right
now what do you guys use for stock
photography or all that kind of stuff
think media tools comm is where that
website it we just have a breakdown we
use so many different stuff look you
don't need all that stuff to start let
me be clear you got to just punt you got
to start before you're ready go raw go
live on Facebook you could go live
straight from the app for free you
already have a smartphone you already
have shoeboxes probably or a box or a
chair and you can just mount your phone
up and just hit record hit live and go
live and then upgrade as you go but in
this journey if you want to turn pro you
want to level up you want to be able to
share your screen like I was just
sharing and like do little things like
this and whatever else put your brand up
in the upper right
although I don't know how many times I
need to have think media hunt screen I
got thinking my hat think behind me
think but that little brand I mean
little things like that real easy to do
on stream yard and you got the power by
stream yard you know so anyways thick
media tools all the different stuff we
use look my friends I know Shannon
Dallin Kathy I hope we can connect next
time I got some stuff to prepare I got
my pregnant wife to check on so I
appreciate you being here and hanging
out and on a future coffee with kennel
or look YouTube influence challenge
10:00 a.m. Pt everyday we're going live
then after that we're doing QA and in
the morning then in the evening 5 p.m.
Pt we're going live doing some training
there's something to do every single day
we got a challenge in an action item and
so we're gonna do we do a lot more QA a
lot more deep dive the challenge is
completely free tube influence comm get
registered hope to see you there and get
in the Facebook group if you're watching
this you register but you're not in the
Facebook group you got to make it all
the way because that's what's going down
that's where the party is
and it all starts tomorrow but if you're
watching this on a replay go to tube
influence calm for the details of how to
get access to everything excuse me so
hey smash like if you got value out of
this video catch the replay if you want
to you know learn about analytics and
some of the things we talked about up
front you want to make sure you're in
this private Facebook group so get in
and work it's going down soon for the
challenge and I want to encourage you if
you want to learn more about analytics
just click or tap the screen so we've
got a playlist on some other tips about
YouTube analytics click or tap the
screen to watch that smash like if you
got value out of this video this has
been coffee with candle 0-0 I have no
idea 0:06 maybe I don't know appreciate
you can't wait to see in the next one
and keep crushing it keep smashing it
and we will talk soon
peace